they have a word it sort of became
old-fashioned it's called a nationalist
and I say really we're not supposed to
use that word you know what I am I'm a
nationalist okay well president Trump
has defended his use of the term
nationalism as an intense love of one's
country but leftist commentators and
other internationalists say it's a dog
whistle battle white supremacist and now
an occasion commemorating the 100
anniversary honored year anniversary of
the Armistice ending World War one
French president Emmanuel macron has
joined the fray literate ISM is the
exact opposite of nationalism
nationalism is a betrayal of patriotism
by saying aren't rest'
who cares about the others well joining
me now Yoram hasn't he he's the author
of the book the virtue of nationalism
and marks a makovski former NATO chief
of staff Urim let me start with you now
what does macron get wrong here about
nationalism
well lorem Makran is pursuing the same
agenda that he's iterated repeatedly
since he's elected president of france a
year and a half ago just in October at
the United Nations macron told us he
deplores a a world world that he calls
the world of lawlessness in which
everyone pursues their own interests
Makran has a problem with the idea of
national interest he says that national
interest is national selfishness and now
and now he's telling President Trump
that to be a nationalist and to pursue
your own interests is a betrayal of
moral values alright mark this is what
Christian Whitten is saying about
macrons commentary let's watch I think
macron within the EU is under a lot of
pressure frankly Germany is willing to
cut a deal on the trade the changes that
Trump wants to lower tariffs across the
board macron doesn't like that he
doesn't like the pressure he doesn't
like having to spend more on the
military he doesn't like the fact that
Italy is
along with Britain sort of peeling away
from the EU not quite as directly yet
Eastern Europe not as kosher on the EU
so a lot of these things just aren't
going the way that this former
investment banker would like them to go
at market if if globalism of the sort
that Makran loves and internationalism
was helping the average you know German
or Frenchman there wouldn't be a
backlash against internationalism or
globalism there would be yeah let's do
more of it but they're under enormous
pressure are they not they absolutely
are
I think this speech there's two parts of
this speech one is a Crone is
encapsulating himself as an opposition
to Trump and he's betting that the
French people believe in our supportive
of an anti Trump for as the national
front are pushing back on hammer
absolute obviously they've had gains in
recent polls in recent local election
this is risky for McCrone because he has
European elections coming up next year
which will be the first barometer for
his own term he's trying to put himself
in polar opposite to Trump and of course
he's isolated because mrs. Merkel also
his political ambitions are on the
decline but also I think this was a
warning this speech was a warning to
those that believe that the nationalism
and populism that fuelled World War one
is on the rise and is a danger to the
European continent I think he was brave
in making that statement at the speech
yoram this is what zenab the sabe said
today about what nationalism actually
creates let's watch what led to World
War one and World War two is nationalism
basically it is divisions and fighting
European allies have seen the worst has
seen actually the consequences of what
nationalism could destroy their own
countries and so when macron says about
collaboration and fighting together for
the common good when he talks about
creating a European army you have to
watch for these things and I feel like
this is the beginning of the European
separation from an earlier bridge and
this is really scary this is really
scary why why is it scary for Europe to
spend more money on Europe's defense a
hundred years after the World War 1
armistice why is that
calamitous to the internationalist I'm
not following that this is the same
propaganda that we've been hearing from
liberal intellectuals in Europe since
right after World War two
they always have the same mantra that
nationalism caused the world wars now
historically if you go after World War
one and you actually see you'll see that
that most people after World War one
believed that what caused the first
world war to go on for four-and-a-half
years and to lead to 20 million deaths
was the the life-and-death struggle
between German imperialism trying to
break the bracket back of British
imperialism in its effort to take over
the world after world war two with world
war ii you can save the same thing adolf
hitler if he hadn't wanted to take over
the world if he hadn't said in meine
Kampf that his goal was to to make
germany the lord of the earth and
mistress of the globe well he might have
been a terrible german leader but he
would not have led to the deaths of 50
or 60 million people his claim yeah I
see what you're saying but Marco just
very quickly respond to that
nation-building wanting to transpose our
view of democracy on other nations
we've lost trillions of dollars
countless lives damaged lives at home
depleted our military we weren't
pursuing a nationalist agenda in Iraq or
Afghanistan or all throughout the Middle
East where we know but I think what mr.
McCrone is saying is that Europe has
maintained peace when the transatlantic
community has been united has cooperated
when the common elements of common
security which NATO represents actually
supports American interests and supports
French German UK interests and there's a
risk today that that transatlantic unity
is falling apart and what are they going
to go to end to the arms of China
where's Europe gonna go I think the fear
is that Trump is going to take the
United States out of the game and that
Russia and China can create conflict
like they're creating in eastern Ukraine
that China is creating in the east in
the South China Seas and the US won't be
there to help secure the people all
right gentlemen fascinating conversation